Some were highly anticipated, some looked
intriguing on the surface but failed to deliver,
and some struggled to even make the public
aware of their existence, but they all have
one thing in common: they tanked badly at
the box office.
Solo: A Star Wars Story opened in May to a
shrug from audiences, and its underwhelming
box office left it the first film in the Star
Wars franchise to be branded a bona fide flop.
The red flags seem obvious in retrospect:
from original directors Phil Lord and Chris
Miller departing late in production to incoming
director Ron Howard reshooting three-quarters
of the movie, it seemed as if everything that
could go wrong did.
While Donald Glover provided a bright spot
as a young Lando Calrissian, Solo felt unnecessary.
Star Wars fatigue may also have been a factor
in the film's failure, and the decision to
open the film while Avengers: Infinity War
was still in theaters may have played a part
as well - somewhat ironically, it wasn't just
one thing that sunk Solo.
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson starring in your
picture is usually a pretty safe indication
of box-office success.
"Daddy's gotta go to work."
Unfortunately, 2018's Skyscraper left audiences
supremely uninterested - perhaps due to the
fact that the film leaned a little too heavily
into its throwback action movie roots.
Even critics who were entertained found it
to be incredibly derivative.
With a $125 million budget and an expensive
advertising campaign to match, Skyscraper
would have had to do gangbusters overseas
to avoid losing money, and it didn't quite
manage it.
Whether crowds were turned off by the familiar
story or experiencing a bit of a Rock fatigue,
Skyscraper turned out to be a whiff for the
magnetic star.
The John Travolta biopic Gotti got a lot of
press due to its star and subject, infamous
mob boss John Gotti, leading up to its screening
at Cannes.
But its reception at the festival was less
than rapturous, and upon its June release
in the U.S., few critics even bothered to
review it.
Literally every single one that did heavily
panned the film.
Every aspect of the film's production was
blasted, from its lack of coherent themes
and ham-fisted direction to Travolta's "distractingly
terrible" lead performance.
The movie failed to even make back half of
its paltry $10 million budget, and those involved
in its production only need to watch the film
to see why Gotti flopped so hard.
Alpha tells the story of a prehistoric youth
who becomes separated from his hunting group
and partners up with a lone wolf in order
to survive.
It's a thrilling, gorgeously-shot adventure,
but while the film scored with critics, it
failed to connect with audiences.
With an advertising campaign which seemed
to be aimed more squarely at dog lovers than
fans of epic adventure, Alpha simply didn't
generate the kind of positive word of mouth
that it needed.
It also had the misfortune of squaring off
against Crazy Rich Asians and The Meg, two
surprising hits that cleaned up at the box
office.
Alpha failed to make back its budget domestically,
but it seems destined for a robust second
life on home video.
After years of development, Brian Henson - the
son of legendary Muppets creator Jim Henson
- finally got to bring his passion project,
The Happytime Murders, to theaters.
Unfortunately, said passion project was the
opposite of everything his father stood for.
The vulgar puppet-based comedy was far too
raunchy for fans of Henson's work, and executed
too poorly to engage audiences who showed
up expecting all the raunch.
The film constituted a gigantic whiff for
talented star Melissa McCarthy and an inauspicious
non-Muppet feature debut for Henson.
The film barely made back half its budget
domestically in the wake of withering critiques
and toxic word of mouth.
It's biggest crime, though?
"It's not funny!
It's not funny."
All year long, fans were pumped beyond belief
for The Predator, a fresh new entry in the
series originated by the 1987 Arnold Schwarzenegger
classic Predator.
It had a unique spin on the story template,
a great cast including Keegan-Michael Key,
Thomas Jane and Olivia Munn, and the sure
directorial hand of Shane Black - who, as
an actor, appeared in the original film.
All the pieces were in place, but a funny
thing happened on the way to the multiplex:
they forgot to assemble those pieces into
a watchable movie.
Black and company seem to have overestimated
the public appetite for the sequel beyond
the original's fanbase, and the film itself
simply failed to deliver for those that did
see it.
Aside from being an adaptation of a beloved
novel, A Wrinkle in Time encouraged high expectations
with a stellar cast and obvious commitment
to diversity.
It was the first big-budget tentpole film
to be directed by a black woman, Ava DuVernay
, and the cast included Mindy Kaling, Reese
Witherspoon, and Oprah Winfrey.
Unfortunately, audiences simply failed to
materialize, and, perhaps due to lukewarm
critical response, the usual Young Adult crowd
declined to turn out as well.
The film's convoluted marketing certainly
didn't help matters, confusing audiences unfamiliar
with the source material's complicated plot.
Overall, A Wrinkle In Time took in just over
$100 million domestically, and it didn't fare
much better overseas.
Action Point had an absolutely golden premise.
Based on a notoriously dangerous real-life
New Jersey theme park, the film starred Johnny
Knoxville of Jackass fame as the irresponsible
owner of Action Point.
Featuring plenty of actual stunts from its
seasoned performers, the film promised lowbrow
belly laughs along the lines of the Jackass
film series.
However, fans found the theme park narrative
to be awkwardly grafted onto what seemed like
another Jackass movie.
Worse, even though Knoxville practically killed
himself making the movie, the stunts were
seen as uninspired and the laughs were few
and far between.
Action Point's poor execution was its doom.
Action Point struggled to make back even a
quarter of its budget, leading to the very
real possibility that we've seen Johnny Knoxville
grievously injure himself for our amusement
for the last time.
Despite not being a sequel, reboot or adaptation,
The Hurricane Heist looked like guaranteed
dollar signs due to its high concept and directorial
pedigree.
Director Rob Cohen gave us the original Fast
and the Furious and Triple X, both high-octane,
stunt-heavy films which bloomed into surprisingly
profitable franchises.
The plot follows a band of thieves who try
to rob the U.S. Mint during a Category 5 storm,
and the film appeared to be a welcome throwback
to the intense, Die Hard-esque thrillers of
yesteryear.
Unfortunately, The Hurricane Heist threw back
just a bit too hard.
“Well, this hurricane can change people
from alive to dead.
Se we gotta go.”
“Yeah, I've seen them before, brother."
Reviews skewered the movie for being ridiculously
derivative, full of plot-holes, and poorly
shot.
Audiences stayed away in droves; the movie
failed to break $1 million on its opening
day, and finished its theatrical run with
a return of barely $6 million on a budget
six times that.
Winchester appeared to have both the premise
and the pedigree to be a potential horror
classic.
Dame Helen Mirren starred as Sarah Winchester,
a woman who spent decades building addition
after addition onto her famous mansion.
The real Sarah Winchester may have been plagued
by poor mental health and too much time and
money, but Winchester posited that she was
driven by something more supernatural.
Writer/directors the Spierig Brothers delivered
a nifty sci-fi thriller in 2014's Predestination,
but their previous gig had been as guns for
hire on Jigsaw, which was less well-received.
With Winchester they displayed a distinct
lack of interest in elevating the material,
instead relying on cheap jump scares and questionable
plotting.
Many critics wondered how they were able to
coax the great Mirren into appearing in the
film.
Hotel Artemis is a futuristic sci-fi thriller
boasting a cast that any first-time feature
director would trade a pinky for: Jodie Foster,
Sterling K. Brown, Charlie Day, Dave Bautista
and Jeff Goldblum, to name a few.
The story revolved around a secret hospital
for criminals in a dystopian future, but director
Drew Pierce's preference for style over substance
resulted in what could have been a mind-blowing
premise falling curiously flat.
Worse, the film's marketing did nothing to
pull audiences in.
Despite working from his own screenplay, Pearce
managed to deliver a picture that felt half-baked
and aimless.
Even its kindest critics viewed it as little
more than "pretty cool to look at," which
was nowhere near enough to engage audiences.
Despite its modest $15 million budget, Hotel
Artemis didn't even crack half that at the
domestic box office - as any good hotel owner
will tell you, you just can't turn a profit
with that kind of vacancy rate.
Annihilation, based on the acclaimed novel
of the same name, is by most accounts a very
good film.
Natalie Portman heads up an amazing cast alongside
Oscar Isaac and Tessa Thompson.
The film's heady premise and assured direction
by director Alex Garland won over critics
- but audiences responded with surprising
indifference.
"I don't know where it was or what it was."
“How is that possible?”
Movies aimed at adults have struggled in recent
years, and Paramount may have exacerbated
this problem by striking a deal for Annihilation's
international rights with Netflix before release.
The film dropped on Netflix around the time
of its theatrical release in virtually every
market except North America and China, severely
cutting into its overseas profitability.
The film failed to make back its $40 million
budget, but considering all the rave reviews,
everyone who took a pass at the theater will
almost certainly catch it eventually - on
Netflix.
NBC's This Is Us has become one of network
television's breakout hits of the last few
years, so it stood to reason that the melodramatic,
family-oriented formula could translate to
success on the big screen as well.
At least, that was Amazon Studios' thinking;
they recruited series creator Dan Fogelman
to write and direct Life Itself, a similarly-themed
feature with an all-star cast including Olivia
Wilde, Oscar Isaac, and Antonio Banderas.
However, Life Itself struggled to a $4.1 million
dollar domestic gross, which can only partially
be chalked up to absolutely brutal reviews.
Critics who caught its debut at the Toronto
International Film Festival ripped it to bits,
and audiences completely ignored the film.
For his part, Fogelman blamed its failure
on critics who didn't understand the film
rather than take responsibility for his almost
comically tragic, over-the-top misfire.
Medieval epics are notoriously hit and miss,
and the latest big-screen iteration of Robin
Hood was far more miss than hit.
Critics savaged the film for its forced edginess,
winking anachronisms and emphasis on spectacle,
none of which would have mattered if the film
had hooked audiences.
But they were a little busy the weekend of
its release - flocking to see Ralph Breaks
the Internet and Creed II, two eagerly anticipated
sequels.
When the dust cleared, Robin Hood failed to
scrape together even half of its budget domestically.
The film's aggressive marketing campaign probably
didn't help matters, as it seems audiences
simply found no purpose in an overly edgy
take on a tale that Hollywood has been telling
for over a century.
The $100 million film is one of the biggest
money losers of the last couple years.
Ironically, it seems like Robin Hood missed
the mark.